c'est l'une des toutes dernières étapes
du nouveau quartier des chantiers plus
de vingt mille mètres carrés de
logements
l'îlot ouest accueillera 176 logements
en accession une crèche et une maison de
retraite les jardins au milieu au coeur
de quartiers
c'est un support de vis social
formidable pour les rencontres les
développements des relations entre
toutes ces catégories
quand je parle des relations que les
bâtiments établissent avec un lieu avec
la ville avec les paysages et avec les
jeunes âgés les habitants ce que vont
vivre avec l'homme
donc on est dans la relation homme
nature et bâti un projet au long cours
initiée en 2008 il intègre aussi divers
pôles de bureau comme le siège de nature
et découvertes
quatre architectes un paysagiste ont été
associés sur la totalité du projet un
gros problème de nos villes aujourd'hui
souffler c'est d'être des villes mono
activité
donc vous avez soit des villes qui sont
des villes de logements soit débiles qui
sont des villes le travail aujourd'hui
on pense à ville autrement on veut des
villes équilibré où il ya la fois autant
d'activités économiques que de logements
et présence de nature l'évolution du
quartier a aussi vu des modifications
pour les transports une nouvelle
passerelle dans la gare ou encore une
gare routière versailles-chantiers voit
circuler 530 et à 85 mille voyageurs par
jour